ready to take it i'm excited about this
too maybe you're ready to take a dive in
to help create a more inclusive nevada
well you certainly did it it is time for
the las vegas plunge raising money for
special olympics nevada and we have
bianca holman joining us live at
cowabunga bay with more details and
you've got the wave pool behind you
still a little chilly though bianca
yeah can you hear the waves going it's
so relaxing i'm ready to rush on in but
i'm not because it's still a little
chilly out and it's cold outside so
we're not going to do that but this
year's theme surfing usa elise so tell
us more about we've got teams that are
going to be here raising money for
special olympics nevada yep vegas plunge
is a team sport for sure and we our
theme is surfing usa because
how can you not have that with cowboy
bay right
but teams come in all kinds of different
costumes so we have a wrestling team i
think under the ocean team all sorts of
teams so really fun time costumes are
encouraged but not necessary just coming
out showing up for our athletes here in
nevada is the important part yeah that's
so incredible and also it's not just the
plunge that you have going on there is
like a duck race tell me more about this
it's my rubber duck derby you can adopt
a cute little duck or a hundred cute
little docks and they will all enter the
lazy river at the same time and we have
at this point i think we're at 20 prizes
so 20 people will win
our top prize right now is a 2022
whole team autographed golden knights
jersey we also have prizes from the
raiders the henderson silver knights
caesars entertainment so much going on
and you can also not only register for
plunge online but you can also adopt
your duck or your 100 ducks all right
perfect and before we go i want to get
shane in here of cow bunga bay what does
it mean to you all for the second year
in a row to partner with special
olympics nevada well we really love to
partner with groups and help promote
their causes and this is such a fun
event last year it was just overwhelming
the turnout and the support that
everybody gave to the special olympics
so it's a fun event and we love to to
partner with community
charities all right wonderful so i know
our time is short but you know what this
saturday come on out it's the official
kickoff can i say official kickoff of
cowboy official yes summer spring is
here summer's here come on out we're
ready to play all right perfect come out
and support special olympics nevada all
for a great cause creating a more
inclusive nevada for our athletes so
we're gonna send it back to you guys in
the studio